hola buenos días con 458 votos a favor-
robert ametzola es la nueva presidenta
del parlamento europeo esta política
maltesa de 43 años del partido popular
europeo será la tercera mujer en la
historia en presidir esta institución y
la más joven de la historia me chola en
su discurso ha recordado que el
parlamento europeo es la casa de todos
los ciudadanos europeos y que europa
debe luchar por que tenga más seguridad
más justicia y también la igualdad entre
hombres y mujeres reventa med sola será
la presidenta del parlamento europeo
para los próximos dos años y medio y lo
ha conseguido gracias al acuerdo llegado
por los tres partidos mayoritarios
liberales socialistas y del partido
popular europeo aún así su elección ha
sido algo polémica porque revert
ametzola desde que es eurodiputada desde
2013 siempre ha votado en contra de la
legalización del aborto porque se debe
tener en cuenta que malta es el único
país
y prohíbe el aborto en todos los
supuestos algo que ha provocado muchas
incomodidades sobre todo entre los
eurodiputados franceses que han
recordado que así no se vela por la
memoria de la primera presenta el
parlamento europeo simone veil francesa
ministra de francia que llevó a cabo la
legalización del aborto en francia a los
años 70 sin embargo esto no ha impedido
que robert ametzola siga elegida
presidenta del parlamento europeo ella
ha asegurado que siempre velará por los
intereses del parlamento europeo lo que
decida esta institución como comentabas
mezzo la sustituye así a david alza sol
y que falleció hace una semana por
complicaciones en su sistema
inmunológico